what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay wow this is gonna be undertaking
Shazaam explained uh Jesus do dis cares
been around for a long long time we did
this once with the Joker where we
explained a character who had basically
been around since like the dawn of the
comic industry ah but this is no small
thing I mean it's gonna be kind of a
this is gonna be pretty tough to do in
an effective way anyway um but I think
we could probably pull it off so
originally Shazam made his appearance
back in whiz comics number two in
February of 1940 and he was created by
Bill Parker and CC Beck now conventional
wisdom tells us that the creation of
what wound stead of calling him captain
mama we're just gonna call up Shazam and
I'll explain why once we get to the
1970s and the attempt by DC to bring his
character back but conventional wisdom
tells us that the creation of Shazam was
brought about due to the success of
Superman but in reality that was the
creation of a lot of characters right
Shazam wasn't the only one who was like
that you guys gotta remember when
Superman first showed up and actually
Comics number one and the superhero
genre was off to the races it was a
great gold rush like it's one of those
it was basically a popular trend that's
one of the things you see a trend
becomes popular and then everybody jumps
on to it right like IGN never had a
reason to cover comic books until comic
books became popular because of the
movies then they had a reason to start
chasing the trend and so when you start
looking at those things it's the nature
of this whole you know of everything
that we existed and so when you look at
characters as a whole by and large
Fawcett was not very smart about it and
that's one of the big things that they
ran into I'll talk about that here in a
second but in the last when she's am
first showed up it was Bill Parker it
was Cece back and it was Fawcett
publications now the way this worked
back then was during the 1940s and
really prior to that when we started
getting into like before Action Comics
number one so basically almost any error
between the late 1920s and the the late
1930s sure about that ten-year window
you had what we called pulp magazines
and pulp magazines were basically just
stories that we're dealing with
individuals of you know fantastic tales
but weren't really superheroes we just
say they didn't have like boots and
capes and powers and things like that
they didn't really exist you had like
Phantom Stranger you had Doc Savage
different things like that but that was
really about it we're soon I came onto
the scene it brought in the cup of Ag
landscape and then in turn Fawcett
publications which was largely a
publisher of like new strips and put
magazines and things like that jumped
onto the trend and so the Fawcett
publications created a comic book arm
called Fawcett comics and then you
basically had them say like let's create
Superman and so so again that's kind of
where things get a little murky is
because conventional was
one thing the truth is another and so we
don't really know what the actual story
is really I haven't been able to find it
every story that I've looked at it's
basically sad you know well you know the
the the the president of faucets say
give me Superman without Superman
thus we got Shazam and would that being
the case he kind of went forward
accordingly and that's one of the things
to bear in mind is that with which
Comics number two and the introduction
of Billy Batson he was crazy popular I
mean he outsold Superman by a huge
margin I mean he wasn't even funny yeah
there's a reason DC sued Fawcett
publications and it had nothing to do
with any actual concern over copyright
had everything to do with the fact that
like readers who were buying who were
buying Captain Marvel could have been
readers who were buying Superman and
because the two were so closely
intertwined in terms of their power the
result was that DC had a will
essentially seem to have a legitimate
beef over what was going on with regards
to the character of Shazam but in the
beginning when Billy Batson showed up
like a lot of other characters he was
part of an anthology book the
Scientology book being whiz comics so it
was one of a series of stories are being
published in this one particular book
but Shazam was the standout star and so
what ended up happening here is that by
the following year he got his own solo
series which again was hugely popular
and it lasted some time that really went
up to like around 1951 1952 and the
reason why I say that is for several
reasons in reality one of the things
we've talked about over the years and
we've talked about the collapse of the
Calla book industry then the near
collapse of the industry following the
end of world war two superheroes existed
before us actually Oh before the United
States became involved in World War two
but the popularity of superheroes didn't
actually pick up until World War two and
the reason why was because you were
talking about carrots unless you were
Superman or Batman you were talking
about characters who were basically you
know using their fantastic powers to
fight alongside the Allied powers
against the Axis powers and so it works
for the purpose that it's served the
result was that by the time World War
two ended people were tired of conflict
they don't wanna have anything to do
with it anymore
and so the result was that you ended up
seeing colorful characters begin to drop
off but in the solo series a lot of
things were basically beginning to come
under way you had Bill Parker Cece back
who created Shazam himself and then you
had other characters you started popping
up you had Captain Marvel jr. of Freddy
Freeman who was created by France Herron
and macro macro boy and then you had
Mary Marvel who was created by Otto
bender now Otto bender coming on was a
result of the fact that Bill Parker had
been drafted in the military and so
really this was like auto benders first
foray into comic books when he created
Mary Marvel but the doctor made you know
for Captain
adventures this solo series ran not a
huge amount of time but it ran for a
pretty good clip in this meant that as a
title continued on as it became more
popular it became more of a threat to
Superman and so what ended up happening
here was that in 1948 there was really
what's considered to be a landmark case
in the comic industry national comics
publications versus Fawcett publications
now national comics again was one of two
companies that would go on to become a
DC Comics national and all-american
Fawcett publications of course was by
itself the issue with this for Fawcett
publications was that despite the fact
that they were creating other comic
books outside of Shazam he was her
standout star it was that and pretty
much nothing else
and while the roster had been built over
the years it all centered around Shazam
so if they lost him they lost everybody
that came with him so Black Adam from
Otto bender and and Mary Marvel and
Captain Marvel jr. and dr. sivana and
all that kind of stuff and so as a
result of this in 1948 the case went to
trial and you ended up having it the
presiding judge basically said well DC
screwed up the national halide screwed
up when they initially went through and
published Superman did they let the
copyright lapse on several instances of
his character specifically the newspaper
strips and this basically allowed
Fawcett to essentially come in and
create what was a effectively a knockoff
of Superman and be well within their
rights to do so DC responded by
following the correct copyright and then
it's Hearn appealed the decision this
went to 1952 I'm sorry 51 in 1952 which
went to judge Billings hand and judge
Billings hand passed down the ruling and
sank that in and of himself Shazam is
not necessarily an infringement on the
character of Superman but the things
that he was able to do were were was
basically the the infringement which is
actually a legitimate case and so as a
result of this DC in turn won the ruling
to some degree I mean Fawcett was going
to appeal but the result was that they
were essentially drained of money I mean
the character had dropped off in sales
so they basically had a loss of sales
going for them they they were they were
losing money left and right superheroes
were becoming less popular there was no
real way for them to revitalize interest
in Shazam and so they essentially
settled and what this did is it led to a
decision that was made between both
companies where Shazam would no longer
be printed by Fawcett they would still
essentially own the character but they
couldn't publish any stories about him
so they really couldn't do anything with
him and so the result was that following
that Shazam disappeared off the shelves
of comics for quite some time and then
in turn that went to sue ran becoming
the character that we all know kind of
setting the stage and opening the field
for him to become widely popular under
like more
meisinger and people like that and so
this goes directly into DC trying to
revive it now this is a byproduct of an
effort for for DC to like bring back
superheroes right we talked about this
over the years and different videos that
we've done that that following to
collapse the near collapse of the
industry after World War two the lack of
superheroes and the rise of popularity
of the horror and science fiction genre
that in 1956 with DC showcase number 4
DC editor Julius Schwartz brought in
Barry Allen and that Reese sparked
interest in superheroes by blending
science fiction themes with with with
traditional superhero roles the idea
behind this was that over the years
Willian in 1967 the Marvel Comics had
already created the character of Captain
Marvel and this is where things tend to
confuse people at the original outset
the first character to ever use the name
Captain Marvel was Billy Batson under
Fawcett but by the time the character
had been brought back copyright for the
name had basically lapsed and so what
this meant was that when DC and 1973
sought to bring back the character of
Billy Batson they couldn't use the name
Captain Marvel on the cover because
Marvel Comics had claimed it and so
that's when things really begin to
confuse people so as it stands right now
at the time this video is being written
and forevermore Marvel Comics will own
the name Captain Marvel in terms of the
cover form for the character in terms of
the first person to ever actually use
the name that's Billy Batson but because
of the fact that the character really
couldn't be used anymore by DC they
simply rechristen him as being the
character Shazam so because of the fact
that that's the word he shouted in order
to gain his powers and that was the
interesting thing behind all this is
because when you look at the original
origin of Billy back in the 1940s he was
basically a kid who was on tough times
and he was taken into a subway system by
a guy wearing a trench coat and he was
brought before an old man who said if
you say this word Shazam then in turn
you will gain powers and you can go
forward as a hero and so on and so forth
but that's what made Billy so popular is
because Billy was basically a kid who
worked for the Wiz radio station and
would essentially break the fourth wall
by addressing the reader in saying hey
guys here's what Shazam did to here's
what Captain Marvel did today and then
tell the whole story of what it wasn't
happened to go on and and so on and so
forth but again going into 1973 and the
attempt by DC to revitalize the
character there were a lot of moving
pieces at work here the first was that
you had carmine infantino who was really
one of the the big pushers of DC during
like the 60s and 70s and somewhat during
the 80s but then you also had like the
creation of the multiverse in 1961 we
got the flash of two worlds and the
advent of the multiverse proper and so
when DC went back instead
okay let's bring back Shazam hurry back
up Billy Batson it will simply call him
Captain Marvel they immediately got a
deceased a cease and desist letter from
from Marvel Comics and they said stop
using that name and so what this meant
was that from that point going forward
Billy Batson could be called Captain
Marvel within the confines of the comic
but the name couldn't actually be put on
the cover so therefore we got Shazam now
would this be in a case because of the
fact that the 1960s are the late
nineteen fifties in the mid 1960s was
essentially just like a reshuffling of
the DC landscape creating new origin
stories the idea was to bring back Billy
Batson and that kind of remove him from
like the the Fawcett comics era to keep
some of those things intact but then in
turn kind of reworked the character and
so what we ended up getting here was DC
sitting down and saying okay the sub
caption the original Captain Marvel
can't fit we'll just call him Shazam and
then to be considered the world's
mightiest mortal you know and we'll
start that with issue number fifteen but
going forward from there what we
actually got were essentially two and
once with regards to these comic books
you got basically reprints of the old
Fawcett publish Fawcett comics stories
and then you got new stories featuring
the character of Shazam and this was
designed for a very specific purpose for
people who were coming into the
character of Shazam by and large they
didn't know who he was Billy Batson he'd
been gone for 20 years by the time his
character showed up so people who were
going in and reading comics for the most
part had no clue who he was and so we
basically got Dennis O'Neil who was
right into comics and we got essentially
backup features these old Fawcett
publications stories alongside news
stories so that people could basically
get caught up on a lot of the supporting
characters the other question that
people had is they said how is it that
this character has basically been gone
for 20 years and nobody knew where he
went to and so in a store in it really
in a combination of stories we ended up
getting this explanation that somewhere
along the line dr. sivana had faced off
against Shazam and the Captain Marvel
family and then froze them in suspended
animation and what this did is it
allowed DC to bring the character back
the problem with this was that Superman
was still wildly popular they didn't
want to over saturate the market with
too many Superman as characters as a
witness meant was that DC invoked the
multiverse and where you had like earth
one which was the main superheroes in DC
that fought alongside Barry Allen where
you had earth two which is where you had
like Jay Garrick the flash is so on and
so forth we got earth s and what earth s
did is it basically allowed DC to bring
back the character of of Shazam and then
throw him into his own universe and say
everything he does here is totally
self-contained and doesn't impact any
else in the DC Universe he did crossover
occasionally occasionally he would
crossover with other characters over the
most part that was really all there was
to it
this this whole idea withwith Shazam
trying to bring him back lasted about 30
40 issues they didn't last very long
and even then issue number 35 was really
more like a backup feature that was
published in the world's finest comics
now the reason why the revival of Shazam
didn't work out and only ran for about
34 35 issues was because people didn't
like the idea of having a character like
that in a totally self-contained
universe by this point in time a shared
universe existed Batman Superman meet
for the first time in in Superman number
76 they team up they stop a jewelry
heist on on a on a cruise ship and then
now like we know that Gotham City and
metropolis exists on the same earth the
characters start crossing over so on and
so forth because that was part and
parcel to the landscape at the time what
was being given here with Shazam was
essentially an anomaly something that
people didn't want to see in addition to
this you're talking about a return to a
character who has written in isolation
almost 13 years after the Justice League
had been formed nobody wanted to see
this and so one of the last-ditch
efforts that was made by DC to kind of
revitalize his character came with
emails and Bridwell alan weiss and joe
rubin steamed as well as don newton
which was to kind of like create more
tangible and grounded stories as opposed
to more fantastic tales of science
fiction themes and stuff like that but
again didn't really work out and so the
results of this was that by the time you
ended up getting into the later issues
of world's finest and so on and so forth
the whole thing had basically just been
like dropped off now following that like
what DC had at the time was essentially
leftover material they had stories that
just weren't gonna be able to be
published because of the fact that this
solo series had been cancelled and so
over the course of really like you know
September to October of 1982 what we
ended up getting were like these little
leftover holdover stories publishing
like adventure comics world's finest
different things like that just sort of
letting it drop off now following this
and going into 1986 really like the
post-crisis landscape under Roy Thomas
DC tried to rework the character of
Shazam yet again the problem with this
was that it was fraught with nothing but
just editorial problems and ultimately
didn't really see the light of day the
idea behind this came out of a 1986
miniseries that was called legends and
legends was really a way for for Keith
Giffen and jmd Mateus to kind of
springboard like new characters and
stories and so what they did is they
reintroduced Shazam as part of the
legend series that way it would kind of
new readers with who his character was
and then in turn that would spin off
into its own solo series that was
supposed to be called Shazam the new
beginning now this was written by Roy
Thomas through a host of other artists
the problem with this was that it didn't
work out because there were just a whole
bunch of editorial problems it was
really Roy Thomas bumping heads with DC
pretty consistently so the result was
that ultimately it never really came to
fruition we never really saw anything
come out of it and so for the most part
between 1986 running up until about 1989
there were efforts that were made by
guys like John Byrne and so on and so
forth to try to like bring Shazam back
but it just never really in a really
worked that way and you know nothing
ever really came out of it and so the
reality of this was that from the time
that his series was canceled pre-crisis
up until about 1991 he'd vanished yet
again now in 1991 this this saw Jerry
Ordway come on by they'd still be
writing a series called the power of
Shazam now in reality the power of
Shazam of well at least the way it was
originally done as it was a graphic
novel and the graphic novel would be
thrown out there by DC in an effort to
test reception and if people liked it go
into a solo series and in truth like the
original graphic novel was hugely
popular all people loved it because what
this did is it basically took a look at
the character of Shazam from the time he
was first introduced running all the way
up to his cancellation in 1950 to 1953
his return is in the mid 1970s his
eventual cancellation again and then an
attempt to return him input in 1986 look
to that whole thing and basically said
what's essential here and what it did is
it wiped out everything that basically
came post-crisis so like Shazam the new
beginning was essentially gone the
stories were written by John Byrne in
Action Comics those were basically gone
instead what the story did is it took
the character of Billy all the way back
to his roots to the old Fawcett
publications stories and they kind of
like read it as origin but maintain the
themes that would keep it updated for
the modern reader now because of the
fact that the the graphic novel was so
popular this led to the actual solo
series itself which ran for about 47
issues but 46 of them are written by
Jerry Ordway now for most people out
there who are familiar with the
character of Shazam this is usually
where they started that's where the
reasons why there are so many fans out
there for his character who loved this
era who love like this run this this 46
issue run by Jerry Ordway because for
them it's the definitive run that
established him the problem with this
was that again DC was really kind of
experiencing a tumultuous time with
their landscape after crisis on Infinite
Earths because where that story was
designed to kind of clear the landscape
of the multiverse and a sort of reset
everything to essentially reboot there
were
still themes that were kind of left
hanging and so you went no light 93 94
95 you going to like you know zero our
crisis in time you go into the mid-2000s
where you have infinite crisis then you
have final crisis and you have like all
these stories that were worked on in an
effort to kind of like rework the DC
landscape Shazam was kind of caught in
the middle of it all you know and so
what this meant was that for his
character you know following the
conclusion of the power of Shazam story
instead of DC canceling him what they
actually did is they threw him on a
series of different publications for
example he showed up in JSA during the
events of 52 uh you know with regards to
Infinite Crisis you ended up having Mary
Marvel who basically lost her powers
then you had Captain Marvel jr. who lost
his powers all as a result of the days
of vengeance when the original Shazam I
guess really uh the wizard Shazam the
one who gave them all their powers was
killed by by the specter this led to
Billy Batson basically leaving his role
as being Shazam the superhero and then
going to be the wizard Shazam on the
rock of eternity which left the role of
the Earth's superhero Shazam open which
they tried to fill with Captain Marvel
jr. it was all he seven always in an
effort to kind of like try to rework the
Shazam mythos the issue with this was
that for the most part not enough had
really been done to warrant reworking
his character you're talking about a 46
issue monthly series so 46 months passed
so you know around four years passed and
Shazam is just now really being
introduced to like the readership out
there but because of the fact of the
sales were slumping a little bit and
because DC was trying to rework things
they essentially reworked him
unnecessarily
and so what this basically meant was
that people were a little more confused
and really the stories were a little
worse for wear
following this whole reshuffling and and
so on and so forth and so what this
basically meant was that going from the
time that power of Shazam ended with
issue number 47 so we're talking 1999
running all the way up until 2011
Shazam never had a solo series it was
really just him and other people other
members of the Marvel family who were
featured in like different books it was
one of these scenarios were scared to
kind of bounced around but it also gave
people the ability to see him in ways
they wouldn't normally be able to see
him if his solo book wasn't selling that
well then the nobody was really reading
it and if nobody was really reading it
dammit that most people weren't really
familiar with what his character was
about what was going on and if that was
the case then put him on JSA a book
that's selling better written by Geoff
Johns and then give people Leo an intro
to his character it was kind of a way to
sort of go back and to say okay let's
try this again but in a different way
now one of the cool things that again
came out of this the trial of Shazam was
this 12 issue maxi series it was based
saying okay let's rework the character
of Captain Marvel
let's rework the character of Captain
Marvel jr. let's rework the character of
Mary Marvel and so what this did is it
actually led to freddy freeman trying to
prove himself worthy of taking over the
character of Shazam following the death
of the wizard Shazam and Billy Batson
taking over the wizard of Shazam's role
so again it was it was kind of a way to
sort of rework them to get people
interested in seeing them in a different
way but at the end of the day it just
didn't quite stick it was cool but it
just didn't quite stick that well and so
this goes into 2011 with the it really
was a line YDC reader now in reality the
2011 reboot of DC of course as most
people know by now was line wide which
basically meant that it was essentially
DC rebooting everything basically saying
like it all starts all over again
but for the character of Shazam he was
reworked in his entirety but this is one
of those scenarios where fans were
really kind of split the fan base for
people who were new or who got into
Shazam after the events of the power of
Shazam storylines and after really his
his character was kind of reworked y'all
before new 52 for them it didn't really
matter it was kinda like hey like that
that works for me the issue with this
was that for longtime fans they felt a
little bit betrayed and the reason why
was because when you went you looked at
like like Keith Giffen and J M DeMatteis
as runs when you look to the runs of
like Jerry Ordway different things had
to had taken place one of the major
scenarios that had come along with his
character was that where you looked at
old school comics from like the 40s and
50s 60s and 70s it was this idea that
Billy Batson would become Shazam and
then Shazam was his only total
personality he was a whole other person
it was like Bruce Banner in the
Incredible Hulk but when you've got into
like later story tellings that were done
into the 1990s and really the early to
mid 2000s it was one of these things
were like Billy Batson becomes Shazam
but Billy Batson is still there he's
still had kind of has like this
childlike innocence about him which is
what a lot of a lot of people loved he
was kind of like the best of both worlds
it really kind of split the fan base and
that's an important thing for you guys
to be aware of is that when it comes to
characters like Shazam he does not have
the biggest fan base in the world but
those who are fans of him are hard or
they are there are intense fans of him
and again I mean with a character that's
been around this long we kind of have to
leave some stuff out but the fact
remains that when it went came to this
whole thing you had like I kind of cared
to redesign you had these small little
things that went on but one of the most
notable instances of Shazam in the new
52 era
is he didn't have a soul
series and the reality of this was
because there was just really no room
for DC was publishing like a ton of
comic books and the character of Shazam
was a gamble the reality of this is that
there's no guarantee as character will
sell and so it was a very big
publication risk given the amount of
money that was already being put forward
the existing line of comics to throw
Shazam into his own book and see what
would happen and so what this meant was
that with issue number seven of Justice
League new 52 Justice League running all
the way up until issue number 21
he received backup he was basically a
backup feature meaning that he was at
the end of the book this was designed to
be some kind of rework him in his
entirety but also bring back everything
that fans were familiar with so Mary
Marvel came back and Freddy Freeman came
back and then there were like
introductions of new characters that
would kind of expanded the Shazam lineup
in different things along those lines
but it was basically it served the
purpose of kind of like returning him to
familiarity but also sort of making him
new the problem with this was that we're
you know the backup features ended and
then he in turn joined the Justice
League fought alongside the Justice
League in two things i trinity war
forever evil and darkside war and so on
and so forth his powers were changed up
but then rebirth happen any vanished and
nobody knows where he's been ever since
we saw him once in Hellblazer rebirth
but he was there when one of them was
talking to him for a minute or two and
just said well we'll let Constantine
consoling to his own thing and we don't
know where he's been ever since we have
no idea what he's doing
and that's one reasons why a lot of
people who were looking at the the
upcoming solo series right now kind of
have this take where they say we don't
know how to view this we don't know if
what Geoff Johns is going to do it's
continued what was done in the the new
52 reboot or if he's going to rework the
character his entirety and we're gonna
get a return to the power of Shazam
stories one half of the fanbase wants to
return to the way things used to be and
then you want fans who want to return
you who will who basically want a whole
new take on the character we won't know
it - the book drops but again this has
occurred - has been around for a long
long time be able to cover him in his
entirety that's a multi-part series when
you're talking about like a seven part
series on the history of his cure if you
want to cover everything but that's one
of the crazy things is that over the
years the powers of Shazam have also
sort of been reworked you know in a
large number of ways in the old stories
if Billy said the word Shazam under any
circumstance he would change in later
stories that began to shift away because
any started running into problems you
know well what happens if Billy like if
he's walking down the road and somebody
runs up on him with a side that says
Shazam and then he says it busy turn
into Suzanne really accidentally says
Shazam or something along those lines
but again in order to tell like
practical stories that essentially went
away originally it was based off the
idea that that each letter stood for a
particular
character that he gained his powers from
so s was the wisdom of Solomon H was the
strength of Hercules a was the stamina
of Atlas Z was the power of Zeus a was
the courage of Achilles and then in for
the speed of mercury and that was that
was really it the carriers that he's
gotten his powers have changed over time
especially when you get into like
Darkseid war is a whole new host of gods
but by and large it always stays the
same the the basis of his powers almost
almost never ever changed wisdom
strength stamina raw power courage and
speed those are kind of universal across
the board the powers of Superman they
never really shift but again his carrier
is also sort of intertwined with magic
and that was one of the big differences
between Shazam and Superman proper his
Superman was basically just like what
would happen if a guy was an alien he
was exposed to a Yellow Sun and then he
was just like really really strong and
powerful and like that's it it's
basically the the mutation of his cells
they give him his abilities Billy gets
his powers from magic as one of the
reasons why whenever you see him go in
like an all-out knock-down drag-out
brawl with Superman that he can usually
win because Superman has a weakness to
magic so it's one of those strange
little situations that goes on there but
it's kind of a cool situation you know
no less hopefully this video gets you
guys prepped enough to understand what's
going on with this character again
there's a lot of history to cover there
and not enough to do it all in a
reasonable amount of time but hopefully
it works for you guys and hopefully get
you guys pretty prepped for his
character so with that being said we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to comets explain make sure
you guys at the sub button to become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]